welcome to ssible Highbury
[Music]
hello I'm Hannah Hart and welcome to
edible history the show where we bake
for old times sake today we're slicing
into the history of the red velvet cake
it seems like the past few years have
seen a red velvet explosion but where
and when do these colorful cakes come
from since I haven't read too much on
this cake I'm talking with Stephen
Schmidt a food writer researcher and
member of the culinary historians of New
York
Stephen thank you for being here on
edible history today we're talking about
the history behind the red velvet cake
can you tell me a little bit about the
history behind this cake that's what's
interesting about red velvet cake is
that all of a sudden it exploded so it's
only recently become popular because
it's it's kind of ubiquitous now you see
it everywhere red velvet cake is the
avocado toast of cakes so who would have
been making these fancy frivolous cakes
these would have been made by
middle-class housewives these were Kings
that were brought out at parties
gatherings of women sewing clubs tea
parties that sort of thing or something
for education can you tell me a little
bit about the recipe we'll be making
today this is from mrs. Lincoln Boston
in 1883 there were a lot of ways of
getting a red color your gig is with
Ksenia which is made with
funk did they step on a bug and it was
red and they thought oh my god I'm gonna
set that in a cave references to coach
Neil in English resident is going back
to the 17th century and possibly earlier
well we'll see if making this cake turns
out to be a piece of cake
wish me luck Stephen thank you so much
for being here today's recipe for
Harlequin cake comes from mrs. Lincoln's
Boston cookbook our first step in making
our cake involves the reddening
to get the red color will be using coach
Anil which is a type of Mexican bug when
I walked over to the table I thought
this was straight-up peppercorn these
bugs are what gives the cake its pinkish
red color
you know normally when we have something
I've never seen before I taste it right
away I do not feel compelled to do that
step number one we're gonna turn on our
heat and add our coach a nail Wow
that is starting to change color right
away look at that it's almost a fuchsia
you know you could have told me it was a
dried berry and I would have believed
you next we'll be adding our alum and
lastly our cream of tartar notify quick
little stir that's a pretty color for
the cake now we just let this cook for
25 minutes
[Music]
25 minutes later our bug juice has this
beautiful rich fuchsia color the next
step in our recipe calls for salt of
tartar that was an early leavener that
we can't really get our hands on today
nor do we want to because there are some
slight safety precaution concerns
instead we're gonna be using a standard
substitute baking soda DVD baking soda
give it a little stir the world and last
but not least our sugar I wonder how
much of the color's gonna get diluted I
really hope it stays this vibrant almost
fuchsia color
now that our sugar is completely
dissolved we're gonna turn off the heat
and bottle our precious precious food
coloring here's our bottle pretty here's
our funnel also pretty if you're a
Hannah you're prone to spilling but if
you spill any of this it'll stain good
luck
we're going to very carefully ladle it
into our bottle we've got bugs we've got
a questionably dangerous salt of tartar
I feel like I'm making a potion right
now
okay we'll get this last little bit all
right our last bit of bug juice has been
bottled and boy is it beautiful
now it's time to make our cake batter so
first step creaming the butter to do
that we're gonna be using butter sugar
and our egg yolks butter and our sugar
and three egg yolks beautiful
now we creamed together which basically
just means makes your butter with this
stuff but they call it creaming together
because they like having a different
word for things and voila the butter is
creamed next we add the milk cute
beautiful young now we move on to our
dry ingredients first things first we
add a little bit of flour a little bit
more now some baking soda and more cream
of tartar okay beautiful okay there you
go there you go now this is really
starting to look like cake batter and
last but not least our egg whites rejoin
your yoki brethren
now we're gonna divide our batter into
four equal parts our next step says is
have two parts the color of the dough
color the third with two squares of
unsweetened chocolate we've got our
melted chocolate right here color the
fourth with pink coloring and bake each
part in a Washington pie plate why not
chocolate oh yeah baby mmm unsweetened
and bitter as night and last but not
least our bug juice we're only adding a
tablespoon because this is pretty brave
now we mix it together Wow look at that
vibrant pink now we move our batters
into our pans good ol mrs. Lincoln
definitely has some instructions about
baking in general cake is baked when it
shrinks from the pan and stops hissing
our batters are in our pans and now
we're ready to take them off to bake
I'll just do this in waves
our next step is to make our lemon jelly
before I do this I'd like to shed a
little light on what type of person mrs.
Lincoln was though we didn't know her
directly let's just say mrs. Lincoln is
a type of person who left no stone
unturned and wanted to make sure that
people knew exactly what they were doing
I'd love to read to mrs. Lincoln's work
on beating tip the bowl slightly and
hold the spoon so the edge scrapes the
bowl and bring it up through the mixture
and over with a long quick flop to the
opposite side under and up through again
lifting the spoon out of the mass and
cutting clear through scraping the
bottom with every stroke if you haven't
thought that deeply about beating don't
worry mrs. Lincoln has done it for you
one cup of water great then it calls for
it the grated rind and juice of one
lemon I absolutely love zest mmm makes
you feel strong loop and the juice of
one lemon now that you got your zesty
lemony eggy water it's time to move on
to the next step so in this bowl we'll
be preparing our one cup of sugar and
two tablespoons of flour and now we can
find there we go
next we're going to take our mixture and
cook it in the double boiler until it is
smooth like cream
our beloved mrs. Lincoln has a thing or
two to say about boiling in fact she has
seven pages worth of things to say about
boiling boiling water which is really
cooked water is the liquid usually
employed water as it's heated from below
expands into vapor okay you know what I
think we're good to move on adding our
beautiful lemony goo to the tub then
grab our whisk we want to be stirring
this continuously as it reaches its
double boil so it can start to become
smooth so it looks to me like this lemon
jelly is smooth like a cream let's take
it off the heat and set it aside to cool
as our jelly cools it's time to make the
frosting now the frosting is pretty
simple it only has three ingredients one
egg white some lemon juice and some
powdered sugar let's do it put the egg
and lemon juice in a bowl and now we
stir the sugar in gradually you know I'm
not gonna lie those instructions on
beating are actually kind of helpful and
five to ten minutes later check out the
consistency of this frosting it's light
it has some soft peaking frankly I think
it looks pretty good now that we
finished our frosting and our lemon
jelly let's see if our cakes is stopped
hissing now it's time to assemble our
cake
the first step to layering is to take
everything out of the pan huzzah we will
very carefully place it on our cake dish
now we'll take the first layer of light
cake and add our lemon jelly to the top
I'm personally a big fan of lemon so I'm
gonna give this a healthy heaping next
our layer of chocolate if the magic show
now we'll take our chocolate layer and
gently place it on top beautiful now you
guessed it another layer of lemon jelly
now another layer of the light cake add
this to the top this is fine I get why
people did this our next layer of jelly
and our final layer the pink the color
really turned out beautifully with this
and to think that mere moments ago these
were bugs bugs okay beautiful now that
you got your layers stacked it's time to
do the frosting spoiler alert this is
gonna get messy I did check mrs.
lincolns cookbook to see if there are
any specific instructions about how to
spread frosting or layer a cake they
were not yeah Hey look well okay it's
okay
Oh mrs. Lincoln I need you now more than
ever you know a big part of baking is
knowing when to stop which is now I'm
stopping I'm stopping I'm stopping there
that is the end of the instructions okay
I'm gonna assume that we should set this
aside to cool so that the frosting can
set before we enjoy it so that's exactly
what we're gonna do
well here we are I'm pretty excited to
see if this recipe takes the cake oh
it's so pretty
I feel the eyes of mrs. Lincoln on me
here it comes
she's beautiful this cake looks truly
stunning but the real question is how
does it taste
okay here we go that's cake it's a
little dry but that's why they serve
okay now that I can talk wowza
delicious a delicious dense rich cake I
love booths okay let me taste this apart
specifically to see if the coach Janelle
has any flavor to it
nope
thank God the lemon curd comes through
so beautifully the powdered sugar gives
it just a little bit extra sweetness
cheers to mrs. Lincoln because this
cookbook took the time to educate and
inform sure it might have been a little
over the top but the message in the
meaning is thing which is that anyone
can bake so long as they have this
cookbook and follow it precisely to a
tee
thank you so much for watching this
episode of edible history did this
episode take the cake let us know in the
comments below
[Music]